[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
muy buen día para usted vamos a hablar
de la organización panamericana de la
salud porque alertó de nuevos casos de
difteria en varios países
latinoamericanos y le pregunto más al
respecto qué información tenemos pues
como bien decías la organización
panamericana de la salud publicó su
boletín epidemiológico que habla de esta
enfermedad y lo que sabemos es que en lo
que va de 2021 ya hay cuatro países que
han detectado casos de difteria
brasil-colombia haití y república
dominicana sobre todo estos dos últimos
en total hay 38 casos en la región y de
los cuales han muerto 16 personas para
saber más de esta enfermedad y para
saber qué implican estas noticias
estamos con el doctor oscar franco
director del instituto de medicina
social y preventiva de la universidad de
berna doctor muy buenos días como cada
miércoles cuéntenos la tasa de
vacunación ha disminuido desde 2010
hasta 2020 de un 94% a un 84 por ciento
eso fue antes de la pandemia que se debe
esta disminución
así es primero quisiera contarte un poco
sobre qué quiere decir teniendo de dónde
viene victoria viene de la palabra
griega difteria qué quiere decir
membrana es que es una enfermedad
infecciosa descrita por primera vez por
hipócrates en es en el siglo quinto
antes de cristo y que se caracteriza por
desarrollar una pseudo membranas en el
tracto respiratorio digestivo en el
corazón y en la piel y que puede ser
fatal y lo que hemos visto es que luego
de muchas epidemias que tuvimos en todo
el mundo y que mataron a muchas personas
en los años 20 1920 1926 tuvimos
programas de inmunización que
protegieron a la población sin embargo
como la cómo se empezó a controlar la
enfermedad yo creo que se ha pasado a un
nivel en que se ha tomado confianza
sobre la enfermedad la cobertura de la
vacunación ha reducido los movimientos
antivacunas han aumentado y toda la
región ha visto unos unos grandes
movimientos migratorios no solamente
internos sino entre países y esto limita
la cobertura no solamente en los niños
sino también en las mujeres embarazadas
en los adolescentes
y por eso yo creo que está bajando la
cobertura usted hablaba de los niños
doctores y le pregunto por qué esta
enfermedad entonces afecta
principalmente a los niños y las niñas
si históricamente afecta principalmente
en menores de 12 años durante el primer
año generalmente el niño tiene las
defensas de la madre entonces está
protegido pero después del primer año ya
pasa a ser susceptible y cuando los
niños se afectan cuando se según como
tenemos vacunas que sirve generalmente
son por programas de inmunización que no
funcionan o que no se completaron o que
no se aplicaron luego los refuerzos y
por eso en los últimos años hemos visto
también unos aumentos en personas
mayores de 40 años y en adolescentes que
están afectados por difteria entonces se
puede afectar cualquier persona que esté
susceptible pero históricamente son los
niños porque en estos el programa de
inmunización es fundamental doctor
estamos en plena pandemia de coín 19
todavía y quería preguntarle sobre qué
impacto ha tenido no teniendo en cuenta
que decimos que han bajado también las
tasas de vacunación a raíz de la
pandemia de kobe 19 pero también quizás
la distancia social las mascarillas han
ayudado a contener quizás los contagios
de listeria también
si la arteria se transmite a través del
contacto cercano puede ser por un
estornudo por tocar la piel o hasta
estar en contacto cercano muy similar al
cubo 19 en términos de transmisión
entonces ese distanciamiento y las
mascarillas podrían ayudar de otra parte
lo que hemos visto durante la pandemia
es que se han relajado y que se han
afectado los sistemas de vigilancia
epidemiológica y el laboratorio entonces
es posible que hayan ocurrido casos que
no se han detectado y que no sean
confirmados debido a la pandemia y hemos
visto que también la pandemia pues ha
limitado el acceso de las personas a
poder ser vacunados y como decías cuatro
países este año ya reportaron casos de
esos 36 vienen de la isla la española de
entre haití y república dominicana y yo
creo que es fundamental que se dé una
prioridad a una enfermedad que está bajo
control y que la inmunización ha ido
reduciendo y que ahora podría salirse de
ese control doctor le preguntó entonces
si es un objetivo erradicar esta
enfermedad
por ahora el objetivo no se ha predicado
sino por lo menos retomar el control y
lo que avisa y lo que trata de ordenar o
de poder recomendar la organización
mundial de la salud es mantener una
cobertura de vacunación superior al 95
por ciento con las tres dosis mantener
los refuerzos hacerlo de forma homogénea
no solamente los niños en las personas
embarazadas también en los que trabajan
en servicios de salud y también
establecer cursos sobre la epidemiología
de la difteria cómo se presenta cómo
diagnosticar la por qué sé cómo no se ha
presentado tanto en las últimas décadas
es posible que no se diagnostica y que
se están pasando algunos casos por alto
doctor en qué momento se considera que
una enfermedad vuelve a ser endémica en
haití por ejemplo se considera que las
historias de endémica pero no se así en
otros países de la región
latinoamericana ahora mismo corremos ese
riesgo
si una enfermedad pasa a ser endémica en
una población cuando la infección se
mantiene una manera constante a un nivel
de línea base sin influjos externos sin
que venga migración o si que alguien
llegue con un caso entonces si no se
mantiene el control que se debería tener
ese 95 por ciento que recomienda la
organización mundial de la salud es
posible que empecemos nuevamente a ver
casos
endémicos de difteria y eso pues es algo
que no queremos porque la letalidad y en
el impacto que puede tener en la salud
de los niños y de las personas pues es
muy grave es muy alto entonces es
esencial que las políticas nacionales de
vacunación de educación de establecer
una cultura de más cuidado y de mejor
diagnóstico contra la difteria serán
establecidas por los países ahora mismo
no solamente en la región de las
américas sino en todo el mundo porque
hemos visto como algunas de esas
enfermedades infecciosas históricas que
se venían controlando empiezan a
seguirse en las manos por estos
reducciones en la cobertura y programas
antivacunas
muchas gracias doctor por toda la
información como siempre nos vemos el
próximo miércoles así es marc doctor
muchísimas gracias yo los despido por el
momento para ir a presentar a nuestra
segunda mitad del día